Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Marcus, Priya, Tomás, Naomi, Ben, James, Rachel, Kevin, Lily, Mark, Greg. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
On my side, the CARE governance framework is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Quick status: licensing and the ADR. On track. I might need a review later but nothing urgent.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
On my side, community review and the advisory process is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
That's fair.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Right, that's what I meant.
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That's fair.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
That's fair.
the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
On my side, the backend capability model and the provenance schema is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
On my side, the manifest schema and validator is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Good point — let's do that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
This retro is different. We're not reviewing what shipped. We're reviewing how we've been working. I'll start with something concrete: the license question has come back three times.
That can mean two things — either new information each time, which is healthy, or it never actually got decided, which isn't. Which was it?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let's confirm in the channel.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Right, right.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the manifest schema and validator.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
That's fair.
Right, that's what I meant.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sure, I can own that.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Makes sense to me.
Partly me. I raised my objection in the channel after the session on the 19th instead of in the room. That's the hallway. I'm naming it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
And I'd say twice it was new information and once it was relitigating. The tell was whether anyone changed their mind. When I changed mine on the 19th, that round moved.
The rounds where nobody moved were the stuck ones.
Agreed.
Here's mine. I went back through our meeting transcripts. In the first three group meetings I was talking somewhere around seventy to eighty percent of the time.
When the lead talks that much, silence stops meaning agreement and starts meaning it isn't safe to disagree. Ben's four-day silence is downstream of that.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Makes sense.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Good point — let's do that.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Alright, moving on.
Bear with me, I'm going to pull up the schema real quick.
The counter-example is the architecture review. Dana proposed open egress, I objected before the decision, and the proposal actually changed in the room. That's the shape we want — dissent arrives before the decision, not after.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
That's fair.
Makes sense.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the manifest schema and validator.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can I name a pattern about me? I don't talk in meetings. I say everything in the channel. That's not shyness exactly, it's that the meeting feels like it's for the confident.
So my contribution is invisible if you only listen to the room.
That's a huge one, Naomi, thank you. It means anyone measuring participation by who talks in meetings would score you at zero and be completely wrong.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Okay, yeah.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Which is the idea I've been sitting on.
What if we built the thing we keep wishing we had — a tool that watches our own collaboration and tells us this stuff while it's happening, not a month later in a retro. Talk-time balance.
Questions versus assertions. Whether dissent shows up before or after the decision. Whether anyone changed their mind. Whether the same fight reopened a third time. All of that is countable from a transcript and a channel.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the manifest schema and validator anyway.
That's fair.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Right, that's what I meant.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Sure, I can own that.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, next thing on the agenda.
I like it only if it measures the right things and stays humble. A number that says I'm 'low participation' because I ask questions instead of asserting would be measuring the wrong thing. Questions are participation.
Hmm, okay.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Right, that's what I meant.
Agreed, and that's a design constraint, not a reason not to build it. Let's spec it. I think it's the most interesting thing we've got.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
One thing: how does this affect the the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the licensing and the ADR timeline?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Mark has the follow-up on licensing and the ADR — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
James has the follow-up on community review and the advisory process — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.